[Music]
European and American farmers employ
Advanced agriculture technology in
modern farming methods to cultivate and
harvest
premium grape varieties transforming
them into Exquisite wine from
meticulously grafting grafted grape
Vines to utilizing Cutting Edge
harvesting machines the process combines
tradition with innovation this
captivating sty Farm documentary
explores every step of grape
cultivation showcasing the dedication
and expertise behind the creation of
worldclass
[Music]
wines the process of cultivating and
caring for grap Vines requires Advanced
Techniques and dedication Farmers
typically start by selecting highquality
grape varieties and Performing B
grafting of grape Vines onto well
prepared rooted graphs after planting
The Vines are nurtured in quing grape
Gardens using all modern agricultural
technology to optimize onam cultivation
and ensure the best growth o pruning
grape vine is a critical stage in this
process removing unnecessary branches
shaping the plants and focusing Nutri
nutrients on the fruit this technique
not only boosts yield but also enhances
grape quality especially in Japanese
grape Farms or high-end Vineyards in
Europe the combination of AI modern
technology and traditional expertise
creates a distinct advantage in grape
production and harvesting expensive
grapes
[Music]
harvesting grapes is one of the most
crucial stages in modern farming and
agricultural production this process can
be carried out manually or using Modern
Machinery depending on the scale and
purpose of the Basham Farm in h when
manual harvesting farmers use
specialized pruning shears to carefully
cut each grape cluster from the qu
grafted grape Vines this technique is
especially suitable for plin Japanese
grape Farms or premium or grape Gardens
where grapes are meticulously selected
to ensure the highest quality it is a
common method in high-end grape
production to preserve the Integrity of
the fruit catering to products like
premium wine or expensive fresh grapes a
expensive grape Harvest
[Music]
on the other hand for larger scale
operations requiring High productivity
harvesting machines are widely used
these machines utilize all modern
agricultural technology to separate
grapes from The Vines without damaging
the fruit some devices are equipped with
regenerative agriculture techn ology to
protect the plants and soil after
harvesting this process is often
featured in on documentaries about
Martian modern
agriculture showcasing the seamless
integration of Advanced Techniques with
practical demands whether harvested
manually or with Machinery this stage is
vital in preparing for subsequent steps
such as transportation to Pon processing
factories or direct processing into
grape based products
[Applause]
[Music]
the process of turning freshly harvested
a grapes into wine is a meticulous
combination of a tradition and calm
modern agricultural technology it begins
with transporting the grapes from the
farm to the ha processing Factory where
they are carefully sorted and prepared
for fermentation both while manually
harvesting grapes and those collected
with harvesting machines undergo this
transformation once at the facility the
grapes are crushed to extract juice
while separating the skins and seeds
this step often features Advanced we
machines to ensure efficiency and
maintain quality especially for non find
expensive grape harvests the extracted
juice is transferred to fermentation
tanks where it interacts with natural or
added yeasts to begin the process of
turning sugars into alcohol this stage
highlights the role of Ori modern
technology in maintaining precise
control over temperature and timing
after fermentation the wine is aged in
barrels or tanks depending on the
desired flavor profile throughout
Innovations in farming technology and
regenerative agriculture practices
ensure the grapes retain their full
potential making each bottle a
reflection of the king grape cultivation
qu process the final product is bottled
labeled and distributed completing a
journey often celebrated in farm
documentaries showcasing the art of wine
[Music]
making now let's head to Japan to
explore how Japanese Farmers produce the
most expensive Bunches of grapes in the
world Japan is famous for producing the
world's most expensive grape varieties
thanks to the Y unique combination of
high-tech Agriculture and traditional
techniques Japanese grape Farms are a
model of meticulous agricultural
practices where each bunch of grapes is
carefully tended from the time they are
grafted seedlings Farmers apply Advanced
Techniques such as grafting and growing
plants in green houses along with modern
technology systems to control light and
temperature the harvesting of these
expensive grapes is done entirely by
hand to ensure each fruit reaches the
highest quality a agricultural
documentaries often capture images of
beautiful vineyards where every step of
care is marked by precision and Artistry
Advanced Technologies and regenerative
agriculture not only improve yields but
also preserve the sustainability of
these rare grape varieties
after the expense of grape Harvest
Japanese Farmers meticulously prune the
grape Vines and clean the grape Garden
to prepare for the next cycle of
cultivation using modern agriculture
technology they carefully remove small
or underdeveloped grapes from the
grafted grape Vines ensuring only the
best grapes grow to maturity grape
seedlings are nurtured with precision
and rooted grafted Vines are mon
monitored closely Farmers then bag
individual grape clusters to protect
them from pests and weather a Hallmark
of modern agricultural practices these
steps often featured in farming
documentaries highlight the dedication
and advanced farming technology employed
in Japanese grape farms for premium
grape
cultivation in Japanese grape Farms
grape harvesting is done entirely by
hand to ensure the high highest quality
for every fruit farmers carefully select
and pick each grape a process that
requires precision and skill afterward
the grapes are meticulously packed in
protective packaging ready for transport
this process often highlighted in
farming documentaries showcases the
advanced agriculture farming techniques
in dedication to Grape cultivation in
modern Japanese
agriculture through this journey we've
explored the Artistry and dedication
behind European and American wine
production and the meticulous care that
goes into the expensive grape Harvest of
Japanese Farmers these stories of modern
Agriculture and farming technology
highlight the passion and Innovation
driving grape cultivation across the
globe see you next time